hi I'm Jordan Pacheco I'm the writer and
director of a bisous taker of children
and I'm Alex even sense of the producer
we recently completed our Kickstarter
campaign we successfully raised two
thousand dollars of our budget in 30
days and now film courage is I supposed
to tell you what we've learned about
running on Kickstarter campaign
Kickstarter is not easy money and it's
not free money it's a big time
commitment you have to plan you have to
organize you have to promote it really
is a team effort everyone involved in
your production should get involved with
the promotional aspect right and Jose
remember crowdsourcing should be used as
a last resort whenever we do one we make
sure we exhaust any other methods of
raising money first such as executive
producers investors even going to small
businesses and asking if they donate
money in exchange for social media
advertising so we really use it more as
finishing funds or additional funds for
our films if you are going to do a
crowdfunding campaign make sure you do a
really compelling pitch video something
that really show the quality of your
work we did a proof-of-concept trailer
for our film showing various portions of
scenes especially highlighting special
effects scenes and dramatic scenes with
the characters to go along with a good
pitch video you also want to write an
engaging description you want your copy
to be very specific about your campaign
about your film and about how you're
going to be spending your funds you also
want to include videos and photos
whenever possible a lot of people won't
necessarily take the time to watch your
entire pitch video so you want to
highlight all the key points in the
description also use graphs and pie
charts whenever possible as well it
really helps to visualize where your
money's going if you run into a dry
spell don't worry most your funding will
come at the beginning and at the end of
your campaign even a two and a half week
low with little to no donations is
common so keep pluggin and still
possible for the reach your goal it's a
good idea to off your backers a variety
of perks of different price levels 4bz
we started as low as one dollar for
behind-the-scenes access and escalated
from there it's important to give people
enough options to choose from but not
somebody that they're overwhelmed you
want to make sure that you create some
unique and creative perks for example we
use the fex props from our movie of
bisous such as a feed
this and a heart that we ripped out an
actress's chest and of course we also
offered the standard movie items like
posters blu-rays DVDs and t-shirts since
you're putting all this hard work into
your project and will not ask people for
help you must be pretty passionate about
the film share that passion with your
friends your family and your social
media network it's really important that
you post often and get personal about it
but don't post so frequently that you're
becoming spammy and once people would
come your backers you should show your
gratitude by keeping them updated you
can post updates in the Kickstarter
back-end like behind the scenes photos
and videos and you can do that
throughout the campaign as well as
beyond because there's so many films on
Kickstarter trying to raise money it's
really hard to stand out you want to do
everything in your power to get noticed
be different be exciting that goes
double when it comes to publicity but we
know from personal experience that it
never hurts to ask thankfully we found
the horror film community to be very
supportive your part should reflect the
pledge amount for instance we did dvds
at early access for twenty dollars
whereas if we were to do it for a
hundred dollars we would have done as
many pledges as it's outlandish and
greedy you really want people to see
your perks Morris pre-releases or
purchases rather than donations be sure
to set a realistic goal for your
campaign when it came to a beezy we
asked for two thousand dollars which
supplemented the rest of our budget that
we had raised through other means you
also want to be aware of the Kickstarter
fees which is five percent as well as
credit card fees which will run you
around three percent and don't forget to
put money aside for manufacturing and
shipping your perks it really can add up
never minimize support not everyone can
afford to donate to your project but
they can share which is extremely
valuable especially if they include a
personal message about why they believe
in you and your film what's the
demographic that you're targeting if
you're making a horror movie like a
bisous you have to prove to people that
you can make something scary if you're
making a comedy utilize humor you have
to know your audience also not only is
it courteous but really benefit your
project if you make sure you're not
running a similar campaign to any of
your peers at the same time thank you
guys for watching and thanks to film
courage for having us on their channel
to learn more about Abby's you take care
of children you can find us on facebook
you can also reach out to us on there if
you have any questions or comments about
the film or about Kickstarter and if
you're watching this you're probably
running a kickstarter
in of your own so good luck with that
and I hope any of this advice helps they
really want you to meet your goal as
well thanks